welcome back to new rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse according to the galaxy's
long-lost missing Easter egg has been
found or a big piece of it at least
according to writer director James Gunn
who made our lives last weekend by
scaring our Guardians vol 1 infinity
saga re breakdown since then a lot of
you have responded wait what exactly is
the Easter Egg I don't um watch your
video I won't draft 12 this tweet
demanding that you explain it thing is
folks my explanation was more of an
omelet delicately folded throughout a
scene-by-scene digestion of the film's
imagery and soundtrack therefore it is
best understood and the film's hold
scrambled totality so go watch that
video but if you hate omelet here is
they boiled down breakdown to the egg
boiled okay I'm gonna try to stop those
egg puns I promise I'm not your dad
except you I'm still at the store buying
SIG's okay I've suggested that be
guardians of the galaxy Easter Egg is a
code hidden in the movies location
coordinates that tells us that Peter
Quill's mother Meredith is actually a
Marvel cosmic deity eternity infinity
maybe Lady Death a space goddess who
continues to speak to Peter through the
movies awesome mix soundtrack perhaps
even Peter in the guardian thinks this
within her
in other words egg equals coordinates
code that's why James Gunn has said
percentages of the easter egg have been
found and that he wouldn't confirm it
until someone found the full thing the
big piece of it that has been found
refers to the work of several others
including the youtuber MT who is one of
the first to attempt decoding
coordinates and building on his work and
years since has been a community based
on reddit and discord who has tweeted
that Gunn various translation attempts
and he has responded with grades ranging
from 50 to 70% translations including
the following the dark asters
coordinates translating to this is mom's
cancer the killed coordinates
translating to this isn't real and no
where's coordinates translating to
Meredith quill excerpt from maybe just
Merrick will see these translations have
been a bit incomplete a bit imperfect
since you know people are still trying
to figure out what more Agins and arts
coordinates mean and since the
alphanumeric decryptions people are
using have to be applied inconsistently
for actual words to be formed but the
discord code breakers are working real
hard and I encourage you to help them
cross this finish line
we weighed in on this egg hunt as part
of this channels ongoing rewatch of the
infinity saga including new vision
details of deeper meanings of all the
Marvel films see we want people to
understand that Easter eggs are not just
random cameos or comic book references
real Easter eggs carries secret
metaphors that give you a deeper
understanding and an appreciation of the
film as a whole so I believe that the
code invites us to rethink this whole
movie as a love letter for a Meredith
quill to her son Meredith died in the
opening scene from a brain tumor that we
later find out what's given to her by
Peter's father ego ego is a celestial
who made it with thousands of beings
trying to find an heir who could carry a
celestial gene but only Meredith quill
could produce a viable offspring but one
after the other they failed me now one
of them carried the celestial genes
until you beat her out of all my spot
only you carry the connection to the
light and that light description is one
that began with Meredith's dying words
about ego and he was stage ego also told
us that he originated as a disembodied
brain floating in space I like the
theory that his brain originated from
the severed celestial skull that became
the setting of know where that location
is where the decoders derived Meredith
and it's colorful surroundings mirror
the colorful background when Meredith
later appears to Peter telling him to
take gomorrah's hand so when Peter and
Gamora listened to fooled around and
fell in love in the eye of nowhere skull
they could be falling in love in the
eyeline of Peters father
gazing out upon the eternal embodiment
of Peters mother whom he wants fooled
around and fell in love with to create
Peter a kind of cosmic wedding ceremony
if you think about it and as I said I
believe Meredith quill is a deity from
Marvel mythology like eternity infinity
or Lady Death now before I crack that
egg open thanks to Ridge for sponsoring
this video the ridge wallet is light and
sleek and industrial it's designed to
fit in your front pocket unlike those
bulky 90 style back pocket wallets some
of those things are bigger than a Funko
pop magneto this one is their aluminum
Tiki design great for when you're living
up the summer it's safely sheltered in
place and hey when you do call for
essentials just take the minimal
Central's with you to make for a quick
hassle-free transaction the ridge wallet
comes in over 30 styles and colors
including carbon fiber and burn titanium
it holds up to 12 cards cash assuming
you still use those dusty old greenbacks
every Ridge wallet comes with a lifetime
guarantee and will let you test drive it
for 45 days and send it back for a full
refund if you don't love it that's got
30,000 five-star reviews so they're
doing something right rich also has
great backpacks and travel bags with
RFID blocking pockets and optional
device charging batteries and hey
Father's Day is coming up in June and
Ridge wallet would make a great gift for
pops and I'm glued to you an
acknowledged bastard son since Ridge
wallets are chainsaw proof they're
especially good if your dad is
Leatherface or ashleighb again get 10%
off today with free worldwide shipping
and returns by going into Ridge Calm
flash new rock stars that's Ridge comm
slash new rock stars and use the code
new rock stars find the link in the
video's description okay I'm thinking
Peters mom is eternity infinity or lady
that's because the film also shows art
inside the Morag temple in the film's
first act which later appears over
Peters shoulder when the film explains
the origin of the Infinity stones the
film's production design companion book
explains that this art depicts the
forging of the Infinity stones and the
four figures around the stones represent
eternity eternity sister infinity
determined these Sun entropy and death
now eternity and death are figures known
for the Marvel Comics eternity is a
cosmic entity the living embodiment of
the universe you know one of those LSD
inspired things from Doctor Strange
comics all the planets and stars are
contained inside it's silhouettes death
aka Lady Death or mistress death is the
embodiment of death and decay the object
of Thanos is affection in the Infinity
Gauntlet comics so yeah in the comics
folks the reason Thanos snaps half of
everything away is to woo this goddess
also one of our discord friends sinister
superspy also suggested gaya
one of Marvel's ancient elder gods of
Earth who in the comics ties in with dr.
Strange's steel of Ashanti and my
explained why earth is so central to all
these events when ego opens Peters eyes
to the mystery of the cosmos in volume 2
Peter goes into this kind of trance and
says
[Music]
in his eyes celestial bodies that
resemble the innards of eternity
now yes Meredith did flatline and Nova
prime did ID her as Terran meaning from
Earth you're half Terran your mother was
of Earth what the way Peter's father had
a micro corporeal form puppeted by his
true macro planetary scale the tumor
that plagued little Meredith as human
flesh could have just been a micro
version of egos tumors that spread like
a cancer throughout the universe
Meredith's human form died but her true
galactic form continues to watch down
and perhaps Peter clearing that cancer
in volume two could have been like an
internal blast of chemo that saved the
rest of eternity
his mother making Peter a literal
guardian of the galaxy now this theory
extends through the film in the form of
the awesome mixed soundtrack which
Meredith gave to Peter and James Gunn
goes to the extreme effort to make
diegetic in each scene playing from a
visible audio source all to remind us
that each time we hear a song in its
movie we're actually listening to
Meredith's speaking to Peter I'm not in
love and opening scene is about a man
hesitant to say I love you like how
Peter in this moment is hesitant to take
his mother's hand later come and get
your love plays over Peter coming to get
the power stone which in this movie
brings him closer to his mom's love
Rupert Holmes escape is about a missed
connection between lovers who really do
belong together just like how Peter
wants to escape back to Meredith's love
fooled around and fell in love plays
when Peter learns to share his mom's
love with another and take her hand the
move that plays a crucial role in the
final battle ain't no mountain high
enough is Meredith's first volume to
track with her letter revealing that the
name star-lord is her nickname for Peter
he is the Lord
aka the heir of a star and the final
image shows and ours three stars which
could represent Peter and ego and
Meredith and I want you back plays as he
takes off toward these stars the 5
Guardians reflecting the Jackson 5 with
Peter one team his mom back the true
Easter eggs are complex and they require
a closer look at all the elements of a
piece to fully appreciate and I think
that's what Gunn meant when he
graciously tweeted nice work see we're
on the right track but he's waiting to
officially confirm it until all the
coordinates are accurately decoded so
technically the hunt is still on or the
hunt is over but we found the goose and
the egg is like crowning we're just
gonna squeeze it all the way out it's
got weird
hey comment down below with your
thoughts and again watch our Guardians
Volume one breakdown or re-watch of
volume two is coming in the weeks ahead
so you can join us in our watch long on
discord by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash new rock stars follow
me on instagram and twitter i da boss
all the new rock stars and subscribe we
write down than everything marvel thanks
for watching bye
[Music]